if you simplify versus go complex
what happens is you can then take your
energy
and your focus and your personal
resources
and focus them on the few things that
will be most important and that's what
the great ones do
don't manage your time maximize your
time
how by doing the things that are the
most
important to do at that moment make
every day
your masterpiece i think one of the
biggest reasons why so many
entrepreneurs
don't take enough action is because when
you get motivated you don't do enough
you feel the motivation you feel the
boldness feel the confidence but you're
not taking enough action
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the
10 steps you can take to become a
productivity
master enjoy
okay let's kick it off with step number
one set clear goals with brendan
burchard
when we talk about work it must be
contextualized in
yearly quarterly monthly
and weekly goals baby like if you show
up to your
kitchen table or the side office that
you set up over in the side of the house
like this
nothing you do really matters unless you
are aiming towards something
that you have a clear vision clear
ambition clear deadlines clear
deliverables
you must know what you're about this
week this month
this quarter and this year what makes an
efficient team
in corporate america or an efficient
team if it's a husband and wife
or you're working with your friend or
your brother
it's all about what are we after this
year
so i begin this entire thing with do you
know what your goals are
by the end of this year do you know what
this month's goals are and next month's
goals are do you know what this week's
goals are like literally as you're
watching this
i'd love for you to think about do you
know the 10 things that you were after
this week
specifically what you're gonna do this
week and if not
let's not fool ourselves that it's oh
gosh working from home is hard
uh because you know i'm interrupted by
this person or that person or now i'm
doing a lot of
virtual zoom meetings no
you don't know what you want that
is the problem you don't have clarity
and no clarity no change no goals
no growth so let's be honest it doesn't
matter where you're working from
home cafe on the road in the car
i don't care at the end of the day do
you know what you are after
so doing the time taking the time to
know what your
yearly quarterly and weekly goals are
absolutely essential
to success step number two build rules
with tom bilyeu
there's often a competing goal in terms
of what you want in the short term
versus what you want in the long term
and one of the coolest quotes i've ever
heard in my life
is don't sell out what you want most for
what you want
right now and i think that is a quote to
live by
right there so that's the big one is
really making sure
that you are focused and excited about
what it is that you want long term and
even just having a phrase that you can
say to yourself
about what it is that you want most i
think would be hugely beneficial so
often people don't have that level of
clarity so when we're talking about
procrastination
just the raw desire to actually see
something through to the end
is going to be critically important when
i think about my own life
and trying to be as deadly efficient
with every single
moment that i have eliminating
disruptions is a big one okay now
assuming that you can't eliminate the
disruptions then you're going to need to
start building some rules into your life
so that any moment where you have let's
say
that rule might be if i have any
consecutive
three minutes where i know three minutes
are available then i'm going to
immediately do
x now that x might be journaling so you
keep
um something like evernote on your phone
and you have a topic
pre-ordained something you already know
that you're going to do
and whenever you have a gap because look
some gaps just aren't going to be
worth it so if i had a 90-second gap i
may not fuss with it
it's going to take 20 seconds just to
get your phone out and get the app open
and have it refresh and all of that
but if you're really hardcore and you
say anytime where i have a three minute
stretch
then i'm going to make sure that i
immediately begin doing something that's
productive
a big part of making limited windows
like that productive is the following
so first and foremost is having an
important things list
and by having that important things list
you're going to be able to immediately
slide into knowing exactly what you
should be doing
so that you don't spend the three
minutes just trying to figure out what
it is that you're going to do
so you're going to have that important
things list you're going to know exactly
what you should be doing you're going to
build in some minimum amount of time
where you say anytime i have this amount
of time or more i'm immediately going to
dive into
one of the things in my important things
list now important things list shouldn't
all be just these gargantuan things that
require hours and hours of time
you want to make sure that you have
things that you can do
that are long you want to make sure that
you have some things that are medium and
you want to make sure that you have some
things that are
short and when you have that now you can
begin sliding into those
some of what you may be doing in the
short maybe researching something
learning more about so you're talking a
lot about film and tv
so i can just tell you right now that i
have a youtube playlist which i also
curate ahead of time
so anytime i've got a brief window it's
what i call transitional moments where i
immediately
pick up my phone take it out go into
let's say screenwriting
boom i've already got 20 videos that are
just going to auto play so i
have to select the next one curate it on
that playlist boom i started going and
now i'm researching
another thing that i can do in very
limited windows of time
is i have specific stories that i'm
going to be journaling on
and i might journal for a minute i might
journal for an hour
depending on how much time i have but
every second that i spend working on
that
i'm able to eat a little bit more
productivity out of it
so that's huge you're going to need to
make sure that you get sleep that's
going to be
really critical and then you need to
prioritize things in your life you
mentioned your wife
so for me my wife is number one now not
in terms of time allocation but in terms
of
importance so when i know that there's
any friction there i'm gonna deal with
that first
when there's um you know i need to
capture joy or something to really
reaffirm the relationship and make sure
that it is this beacon of joy and hope
in my life
i'm gonna do that so putting your your
um
values in life in ranked order is going
to be critically important to you
what's up everybody i want to talk about
the amazing book by evan carmichael
built to serve i want to read you guys a
section this is from
um a part under the heading of your pain
is your strength
this is the fundamental mind shift that
most people never make but is required
for success
the pain that you went through that
you're trying to forget
it's your strength it's the way through
it's your answer
that pain is how you become the tree
you've experienced the pain
grow from it and are stronger now and
are able to help others who need the
support
so there it is your pain is the very
thing that's going to get you through
it's kind of like what ryan holiday says
the obstacle is the way
all right guys check it out build to
serve by evan carmichael who could teach
a master class on how to be a badass and
be good to people
dude is rad check out his book a lot of
amazing stuff in there
step number three focus on important
things with robin sharma
minimalism is a way to set up your
entire life
you see because here's one of the
secrets of world class
do few things strikingly
well most people right now are suffering
and i use the word suffering on purpose
they are
suffering from massive levels of
complexity
whether it's on the social media whether
it's diversion through
through their devices or they have so
many
friends and they have so many books to
read and they have so many social
engagements
and they they haven't stepped back
from the complexity of their lives to
say why am i doing all this
they just think it's normal and actually
some of them have
numbed themselves and it's such so part
of their normal lives
they really don't know they're doing it
and what i'm encouraging you to do is
remember
that history's heroes were not
complexitarians
they were minimalists they had a few
possessions
they had a few friends they didn't have
five homes they didn't have seven cars
they didn't have 40 000
you know followers you know
in terms of like the social media these
people kept
it staggeringly simple and i think
that's really really important
because if you keep if you simplify
versus go complex
what happens is you can then take your
energy
and your focus and your personal
resources
and focus them on the few things that
were
will be most important and that's what
the great ones do
they marshal and harness their resources
their mental focus their physical energy
their personal willpower their
individual gifts their time
i call those the five assets of elite
performance
and they focus them on just a few things
and if you i want you to think about it
in your life
if you stripped away all the noise you
focused on the signal
you stripped away all the complexity you
got monomially concentrated on just a
few things
of course you'd be brilliant at those
few things step number four
manage what you do with john aseraf
there's no such thing as
time management you cannot manage time
the only thing that you can learn
how to do better is manage
what you do in time
now if you analyze or do any research
on highly productive people
they are two three four five times more
productive
in what they do than
other people everybody and i mean
everybody is freaking busy
busy with friends busy with family busy
with
kids busy with a job busy with their
career
busy doing some of it's productive
some of it is not write this down okay
somebody type this
out don't confuse activity
with productivity write it down for me
somebody you know write it down
don't confuse activity with
productivity okay so
what does that mean it means that most
people are
doing busy work and they're confusing
thank you sharina
they're confusing being busy and being
tired at the end of the day
with getting the most important things
done
so that's why i said there is no such
thing as time management
the only thing you can manage is what
you
do in the block of time while you're
awake
when you create an action
item or a list of what you need to do
and you have a deadline to achieve it
your brain actually goes into a hyper
focused mode when you create
self-imposed deadlines and urgency
factors so when we
teach our clients whether they're
employees or home makers or business
owners or doctors or lawyers makes no
difference
one of the things that we teach them in
addition to having a goal
and in addition to having things that
need to get done
is to create a deadline there's
something called the pareto principle
that that that says that if you focus
on the 20 of the things
that are the most important and you
set deadlines to achieve them
you will get your brain to focus on
getting those achieved so
in addition to something called the
pareto principle there's also something
called
parkinson's law when you combine the two
pareto's principle and parkinson's
law to say i'm going to make a list of
everything that i need to get done
but i'm going to prioritize
the things that are the most important
the most
urgent and i'm going to put those onto
my calendar to get them done
first not last not after i've done all
my busy work not after i've
you know been on the phone i've returned
200 emails i've texted
16 friends i've played on facebook for
two hours no no no no that's what
average people who are busy do
versus above average people who are
productive
do you have to change your mind
shift the way you're thinking about your
time and
what you do step number five stop
wasting time with eric thomas are you
wasting your time
or are you using your time wisely are
you wasting your time
now watch this guys statistically we
want to show you some stats right
and we wanted to show you we wanted we
wanted to reveal to you
what the devil is doing 10 time wasters
tv
i should never watch tv i never said
that
but i promise you you shouldn't be
wasting time
i promise you you shouldn't be wasting
time so if you're watching tv
five six episodes or something and you
ain't got nothing done productively you
i'm sorry i'm gonna say like this
you haven't been able to accomplish
anything
effectively and you have
wasted your time you need to stop
tv movies phone
jamie how much time do we spend talking
on the phone
having conversations that we shouldn't
even be on like
that conversation ended 45 minutes ago
you gotta know you gotta know when
you're on the phone and it's productive
then when it's got to a point where it's
not productive no more
it's time wasting social media jamie i'm
just going to keep it 100.
i got to get up and pray every day and
say god when i drop my video in the
morning let me put the phone down and go
pray
sometimes jamie i dropped my phone and
i'm going through my stuff
how many uh people have looked at it and
then they go from that to looking at
somebody's story
then they go from that jamie i don't
woke up 15 20 minutes later
no you heard what i just said i woke up
he you like what do you mean you was on
the phone sleep i woke social media
meaning that i woke up and went back to
being productive
i was in an unproductive comatose
i don't even know what i would jay me if
you had if i had to get a million
dollars for what i was doing for that 20
minutes i couldn't tell you what i was
doing i was just scrolling that's it
just scrolling down i don't even know
what i was looking at i don't even know
what i was doing
unproductive time wasting video games
yup i've been guilty back in my 20s i
was wasting time
some of you wasting time you're still in
tournaments you grown doing tournaments
you're doing tournaments hallelujah
commuting
jamie you know how much time people
waste community like but i gotta drive
to my job why aren't you listening to a
podcast
why aren't you listening to an audiobook
why are you just listening to music
that's not necessarily going to help you
why aren't you getting a degree while
you're in the car
if you got to be in the car two hours
there two hours back jamie four
hours you could have a book online to be
listening to that book and taking
uh uh audio notes right uh siri
write this down you could be taking all
that time you spent in your car
you could have had a degree learn a
second language
exercise you said pastor i should be
exercising
look listen to me very closely give it
30 minutes to an hour go sit down
somewhere
like eat right and you can work out for
that hour and not have to work out no
more
like like you're exercising now exercise
is taking the place of being productive
you could be going to college and
getting a degree or you could be getting
a trade or you could be getting
certified
you exercise because you like doing it
and it feels good
but the results you can get those in an
hour
every day and eat right okay i know all
right shopping
uh oh uh oh i know uh oh uh oh diddy's
watching
diddy's watching
look shopping and i'm not saying my wife
shops because it's therapeutic
right and it's a form of exercise for
her but i'm just saying we got to be
careful
when uh shopping turn into five six
hours three four times a week
right and then okay you like well i
don't go shopping you're online shopping
you online shopping wasting time and
probably wasting money
and then finally jamie i hope this will
make sense many of you are wasting time
with your obsessions
so whatever your obsessions are i don't
know what that is but whatever your
obsessions are you like you might be
playing chess you are obsessed with it
nothing wrong with chess it's an
obsession like uh
maybe doing some stuff around the house
an obsession listen to me i tell my
students all the time who were from
detroit saginaw flint muskegon where
wherever they were from ann arbor me
wherever they were from
uh what brighton wherever i say all the
time
you come in here to get a degree why are
you going back home every weekend what's
at home
right wasting time it's only going to
take you four years
if you finish this degree and you finish
it well and you get internships and you
meet people with that time instead of
you going home
meeting people you've already known
meeting some new people you could get up
out of this joint and make so much money
you can go home whenever you want to go
home
but the way you doing it you're gonna
have to you're gonna be stuck back at
home
step number six dedicate days to do
things with dean graziosi
i don't love zoom calls and conference
calls that go on for so long that my add
kicks in and i just want to scream i
just wanna like jump out a window
like i'm on the first floor so i
wouldn't get hurt i meant run
right um i don't like conference calls
where people aren't
specifically organized and it's kind of
not talking about solution oriented
stuff that's just me personally i need
to do them
i need to have meetings with my
accountants i need to go over
kpis key performance indicators i need
to go over and make sure that our sops
our standing operating procedures are in
place so my company can
scale i need to do all those things but
i don't like it
i'm just going to be honest with you you
know what i love i love being
in creativity mode i love envisioning
where the world is going what people
need
i love to be creative i love to be a
visionary i love to make stuff up
and then obsess on making it real i love
to come up with new ideas on
what my next book will be or what my
next video will be
or what my next course will be or how to
get self-education to really become the
new norm or how to solve big problems
i love solving big problems that most
people think aren't solvable
they light me up but i don't get to do
those things
i don't get to make an impact i don't
get to employ and help people around the
world i don't get to write books that
empower millions
i don't get to do that unless i also do
the crap that kind of sucks
and here's what i know i did wrong for
many years is i would mix
and match i would have a conference call
then try to film a video
and then get done being creative in a
video and say okay now i want to think
of the next
course our training i want to create but
then i get a call from my accountant and
i'd worry about uh
what our fourth quarter projections are
going to be and my brain would switch
back and forth from like
art and science creativity and processes
and it would get all mumbled and
sometimes i feel like i'm not going
quick enough i'm kind of delaying am i
slacking
by procrastinating no because it was
like my brain had to switch back and
forth
so what's the solution is when i do this
right and i'm
urging you to do this when i dedicate
days for specific things
then the world changes i get into flow
state i can get more done in an
hour than i could on regular days in
three or five or what
i believe other people take two weeks to
get done i can do it an hour
if i'm in flow state so i want to
protect flow i want to protect the thing
in my life that moves the needle more
than anything else and that is my
innovation
that is my creativity so i'm going to
give you an example
in my life and then we're going to put
it back on you this week on monday
i'm just dying to film i'm working on a
new course right now that i love i'm
just gonna i'll be transparent working
on a course
on how everyone can be better on video
everybody asks me how to communicate on
video authentically and
real and not get word it's like i'm an
entire process i've been geeking out on
it and i want to create that because
everybody asks for it right so
i want to get to that so bad i've laid
it all out i got
white boards all over my house i got big
sheets of paper like this that i
that i fill everything out on like i
have the whole thing
broken down i gotta get creative but
here's what i know
monday of this week as i'm recording
this for you
i had zoom calls every hour with teams
with different departments with our
marketing team with our accounting team
with our next level uh fulfillment team
with our high-end coaching
and and uh next level education team ad
buyers like i had to go through all
those things this is a big shift in
everybody's business my business shifted
too we
we're all in one building now we're
virtual like lots of busy stuff
and i have to tell you man it burned me
out i didn't love it but i
scheduled it for monday and i can live
with monday
being the day that i do all the crap
that i don't love to do but i must
do you see in business and life if you
want another level it's not all peaches
and cream
it's not all puppies and rainbows you
have to do the crap you don't like
someday you get to hire people to take
it away but there'll still be stuff on
the list
you don't like but you must if you want
that next level you want more freedom
want more control you want to thrive in
these uncertain times
you have to do the crap you don't like
but
i schedule it for one day and i still do
it to the best of my ability and no one
would ever know i don't
like it because i know i must do that
because you know what i got to do on
tuesday
i got to live in my creative space step
number seven have an evening routine
with mel robbins
my night routine is very simple complete
the day and leave
no tasks that i have to finish in the
morning it's that that
that's it and so it's not necessarily
that i have a specific order
but there are particular things that i
do number one totally set up the kids
so that means pack their lunches it
means get the backpacks ready if it's
school season and get them by the door
it means if there's any forms that need
to be filled out or printed or anything
else if they are printed they are ready
to go so kids are
handled second thing i want the kitchen
clean
i don't ever want to wake up in the
morning and walk in there and see
crap that i have to do i don't want
dishes in the sink i don't want
things on the counter and so i make sure
that the kitchen is clean
that the counters are cleared off and
that
there is no nothing i need to do in the
kitchen because it will distract me in
the morning i will feel
guilt i will feel obligated to to get
that done
um third thing that i do is i tend to
set out
the stuff for breakfast and the reason
why i do that is because
my kids will wake up at various times
and so if i've got that thing set up
i've just bought myself a couple more
minutes of quiet in the morning
before the parade of children come
running down the stairs
starving and wanting breakfast the other
thing that i do is i go to my computer
and i print out the day
calendar for the day ahead
and then i take that printout and i take
my
notebook that has all of my travel and
kind of everything that's laid out for
the the business that i run and my
speaking schedule and stuff related to
the kids and i move it all to the
kitchen
now why am i doing this i'm doing this
so that when i
leave my bedroom in the morning and i
walk into the kitchen to have 30 minutes
of quiet time for myself
to get focused to plan my priorities
everything's set
it's all been handled there's no
thinking involved it's amazing
then once that's all handled i turn off
all the lights
i lock the front door when i walk into
my bedroom the very first thing that i
do
i set my alarm and then i plug my phone
in
in my closet that is the single most
important
aspect of my evening routine step number
eight avoid reactive communication with
russell brunson
and probably the biggest time strategy
for me is like proactive time versus
reactive time okay so what that means is
um like i don't like if if somebody
calls my phone rings i will never answer
unless it's my wife like she's the only
person actually answer the phone for
because she trumps all things
but for anybody else i never answer my
phone calls i try to not ever do
phone calls at all i if you've ever
tried to call me on the phone you know
i'm like i don't really do phone calls
either email me or vox me or something
because i like to have i can choose like
okay i'm gonna answer messages
between you know uh four o'clock and
five o'clock today
so from four o'clock to five o'clock i'm
like putting on my getting in the zone
and just
answering my emails listening to my
messages answering it and just getting
all done at once in one block
and that's it that gives me the rest of
the day to focus on doing whatever i
want to do but so many people that get
stuck
in this reactive mode where they're just
every single thing that hits them like
oh and they're jumping here they're
jumping again they're jumping here
they never actually get anything done so
you as a busy entrepreneur is trying to
change the world and trying to create
products and businesses and companies
and and do all these things you can't
be jumping off every single thing you
have to have focus time you're able to
actually work and the biggest thing is
is breaking out your time where um you
no longer let people do
um reactive communication where you're
reacting all the time you have to focus
on the proactive so you shift things and
say okay this is the time i'm gonna
answer all the messages
if you have a question from you have to
send it to me in a way that i can answer
during this period of time
because i can't shift my focus i need to
be able to focus on
what i'm doing right here step number
nine maximize time with john maxwell
you see when you manage something you do
so to keep it going
well you don't need to keep time going
you don't even need to watch it you can
be completely aware well
unaware of it you can go to sleep
doesn't matter time just continually
moves it doesn't need you it doesn't
need me
it just keeps moving we don't need to do
time management because there's nothing
to manage it's automatic it continually
moves
what we need to do is priority
management
with the time that is continually
slipping away from us
we need to manage our priorities to
maximize
the time we have so don't
manage your time maximize your time
how by doing the things that are the
most important to do
at that moment make every day
your masterpiece and step number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip
is break things down with jim quick
break things down
because a lot of people they don't do
this thing because this is amorphous
big elephant or big monster and what i
would say
that makes it more digestible is
breaking things down into tasks
and getting some kind of momentum right
so when you have a big project you don't
want to put the whole project on there
just break it down to the first thing
you need to do
and this is um actually and i'm
borrowing this on on from the science of
tiny habits
out of stanford university by dr bj fogg
tiny habits is like if you're
procrastinating
flossing your teeth for example he's
like you know don't worry about flossing
all your teeth
just floss one tooth like one tooth
and what do you do is anyone just floss
one tooth no of course not the end of
doing a second a third and so on
and that's breaking things down in tiny
habits it's like if i want to get people
reading like we were talking about
earlier making it a habit for reading 20
minutes
don't don't do don't worry about reading
for 20 minutes just read one word in a
book
and then you read the second one right
so you break it down that's the first
advice
the second thing i would say is to
start with your why right one of one of
my favorite books in business
start with why by simon sinek and i do
believe there's a success
formula that goes from your head to your
heart to your hands
meaning that i can visualize things in
my head and think about things and set
goals in my mind and affirm things in my
head
but if i'm not acting with my hands
nothing is happening and so what i would
say is what's usually missing is the
second h which is the heart
right the emotion the energy emotion i
had a martial arts instructor teach me
years ago that
you can't steer a parked car right you
need some fuel and then
and so the emotion gives you the fuel
to be able to move things forward i
would tap into why you're doing things
because
reasons reap rewards reasons reap
rewards
and if you come up with enough reasons
you'll get the action to do it
and the third thing i would say in order
to be able to
overcome procrastination to really smash
it you know smash it like the hulk if
you will
is to um start somewhere to start
somewhere anywhere
and this employs actually a rule in
psychology called the zeigarnik effect
the zygarnic effect basically this
psychiatrist or psychologist
in europe was noticing that when she was
out at the cafe
that the the wait staff was never taking
writing down her orders
and at all and you ever had a waiter
waitress like that you go to dinner and
they take like five or six
when i waitress that was me it's amazing
and then i was as a kid i was wondering
how do they do that because i remember
for me it was like a big belief change
but i knew it was really possible and
what they're executing in if they don't
have an actual strategy for it like i'm
like one of the memory techniques we
teach
um is the zeigarnik effect and basically
what she found when she was researching
it is they would hold that order in
their mind but as soon as they delivered
it the order would disappear
right you know because it was close they
got closure and the zygarde
effect is basically saying your brain
doesn't like open loops
open loops meaning you start something
but don't finish it right it doesn't
like that dissonance um and so it needs
closure
right um like a kiss good night kind of
thing and so what was happening here is
that
they were remembering the orders and
they would hold on to it
until they actually was um delivered and
then
that's the zygarnic effect and so the
idea here is start something
and you'll be you have this impulse to
finish it and you know until it's done
right but you start somewhere as opposed
to not starting anything
and then the last tip i would give
people to overcome procrastination so
you could hit your top three things
today
is to be kind to yourself to be kind to
yourself
because you would think that people
intuitively beat themselves up
over procrastinating you know i didn't
get my i didn't get my workout in i
didn't get
to meditate today i didn't get to make
my green juice my smoothie or
in there you know all those things that
they do and they think that by
being hard on themselves they're more
likely to change in the future and we
actually find
in the area in the research done on
self-compassion
is is the opposite is all is true it's
it's actually the opposite that's true
that being kind to yourself being
compassionate with yourself
saying that you know i'm only human and
it's okay
you know i miss my workout today means
that you're more likely to do it moving
forward
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and you get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of following through that's not
enough but when you write down what time
what place and how you're going to
actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're gonna do it
it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you most people have not taken control
of their schedules
you wake up like an accident start
responding to other people's emergencies
and help
other people build their dreams instead
of you building yours
it's time for a change you deserve
better and this video is going to show
you how
i think one of the biggest reasons why
so many entrepreneurs don't take enough
action is because when you get motivated
you don't do enough you feel the
motivation you feel the boldness feel
the confidence but you're not taking
enough action you're not doing enough i
remember going to my first tony robbins
event this is before
uh i knew tony one on one before i did
the interview with him on my channel
i just went to see what would the event
be like
i've i've seen so many different videos
of so many different people
and i felt like you know what for most
people going to their event
it'd probably be the same as just
watching on youtube but for tony i felt
you know what i think his event might be
different
there's something that tells me by going
to his event it'll be different than
what i just see
on youtube through the content and so i
went and i went with my wife i went with
three people on my team
i paid for everybody to go out and went
to our first tony robbins event
and at the end of the last day if you've
never been to tony robbins event
it's on fire you're motivated you're
jumping you're dancing you're hugging
you're high-fiving you're
you're breaking through limits it's it's
amazing and by the end of the last day
you see everybody in the streets you're
pouring out everybody's all pumped up
and energized
like i'm going to do this i'm going to
do that i remember one of the people
that i brought with me he's like yeah
i'm gonna do all this stuff and he's
like yelling and so fired up and excited
he's like what are you doing evan like
i'm looking at my calendar
because this is why so many people fall
off you go to an event like that and
then you fall off because
you're not making it consistent success
is habits so whenever you decide to make
a change you have to
at least for me i look immediately to my
calendar so
if my goal is now i want to be a big
youtuber great
when am i going to make videos it's got
to be in the calendar it's not on the
calendar
it's not going to happen and so anytime
you want to make a meaningful change you
have to default to thinking
what am i going to put into my calendar
because success is
habits and so it's great to be motivated
maybe these videos do it for you
maybe events maybe books podcasts
awesome you're getting it from somewhere
you feel motivated great show me in your
calendar where you are spending the time
to actually make the thing happen
otherwise you're just living off some
fumes
you know you get motivated for a day or
two feels amazing and then you fall back
down to normal
if you want that dream life you want
that next step for yourself
it's gonna come from changing your
habits changing what's in your calendar
to make sure
that what you say you want out of life
you're actually working towards making
that happen
[Music]
if you want even more tips on how to be
a productivity master check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there and today i sit down with one of
the
biggest evernote experts in the world to
break down
exactly how i run my life and my
business through evernote
and he gives me feedback